if I mandate by law that you have to
sell me I don't know let's say your
grandmother your dead grandmother gave
you a bracelet an heirloom it's very
important right and I mandate you know
what you have to sell that to me but I'm
gonna pay you for it do you care that I
pay you could it possibly be less
relevant why because it's priceless you
can't replace that you know what else is
priceless the right to defend yourself
and your family question of the day what
do you think the Democrats endgame is
right now it's proposing the
increasingly radical anti-gun laws like
a mandatory buyback we'll get to in a
second do you think it's just theater at
this point or do you believe they've
really deceived themselves in or
deceived their constituency into
supporting these proposals so let's get
into some context many Democratic
presidential candidates this isn't just
some random person on Twitter people
running for president proposing
mandatory gun buybacks K program similar
to Australia should come as no surprise
it started with President Obama we know
that other countries in response to one
mass shooting have been able to craft
laws that almost eliminate mesh don't
miss you have government buyback program
in your plan how is that gonna work well
first of all I want to say my colleague
and I both have been hearing this on the
campaign they say well first of all it
means we're not gonna answer your
question first of all I gotta go over
here the sales of weapons of war but
also importantly and politically
difficult to say buy those weapons of
war back mandate that not voluntarily
let's be really clear with our fellow
Americans no place for an ATM is a Hail
Mary for the man from El Paso streets
community dog whistles assault weapons
are already out there that people what I
would do is I would try to reduce the
budget looking at the Sun and I was
making sure that that in fact was we
tried to do get them free a stye yeah I
don't know okay so before we continue
it's important to note that buyback as
its referred to when it when we're
talking my Australia it's an all-out gun
ban period end of story
it's a mandatory buyback at least NATO
was consistent at least who's being
honest about it saying we are going to
mandate this it will not be voluntary
it's a mandatory buyback Australia with
a government they will confiscate your
guns and they'll toss you some pocket
change to try and make it sting a little
less
so how far would this mandatory by that
this gun ban extend many candidates each
I said weapons of war
they use the term assault weapon which
doesn't actually mean anything so first
off I guess if we're just talking about
semi-automatic rifles which was what a
lot of them want to do they want to toss
it all under this umbrella deadly a
school shooting in the United States
history committed with handguns
okay vast majority of gun violence is
coming from handguns people need to
understand that so it wouldn't even
necessarily make a dent even if you
could get all the criminals to abeita
handguns rifles if they could hand over
their I just it's it's not gonna work
here's something else that's important
to know Joe Biden went on to say not
just assault weapons but he's talking
about any gun did you guys see this clip
any gun that has a magazine with
multiple bullets I think he's I think
he's been consuming buckets of salt
water and somebody to tell him that you
need to find a fresh body it has to stop
the idea that we don't have elimination
of assault-type weapons magazines
absolutely - wait what constitutes
multiple - over under shotgun interests
former Vice President Biden added back
when I was vice president that he wanted
to kill his people he had ordered a
drone strike so he doesn't want you to
know that he's not entirely without this
is something important don't want to get
to the wordplay where people was glued
in a magazine to clip he said bullet
hole bullets that's important note it's
not a bullet it's a round ok magazines
hold rounds this isn't just a bunch of
technical wordplay this matters because
a bullet is just a projectile that
usually leaves the gun right it's loaded
into a round this is important to note
because it tells you that he has no
semblance of gun safety around you've
heard the term live round around is the
case primer and the bullet and gunpowder
that's important out because you can
basically send off a live round with a
hammer if you hit that primer think of
it this way four people don't know
anything about guns these two have
muskets right they would put the
Gunpowder in a packet then they put in a
little ball bullet because I didn't
understand ballistics at all or how
things travel to the air apparently even
though they had arrows they jam that in
they would light it it would hit a flint
so a round is a little case with a
primer that the striker hits spark
gunpowder burns and then the bullet
leaves the barrel it's
just important to highlight because it
shows that they haven't done any
research at all I mean either you want
to believe that they don't know or they
know when they're lying it's like the 77
cents on the dollar how does he not have
someone go learn the difference being
rounds in bullets I have no idea because
they don't know either yeah I don't
think that anything it's like is there
anyone in this office who knows what
firearms are all about spotlit I'll tell
you what firearms are all about Charlie
Brown something else is noted guns
weren't purchased from the government in
the first place the buyback the language
here okay
the gun did you go did you go down to
your local DMV and purchase your your
Ruger no you didn't so how are they
going to buy it back from the people
they have no purchasing power by the way
just means you the taxpayer right who's
going to buy it back
you know the taxpayer will foot the bill
to mandate the purchase of other
people's firearms we're going at a Buy
but o oj simpson bought back memorabilia
by the way so let's get to a couple
reasons why the buyback wouldn't work
practically before we get to the
principle as to why it's actually
morally abhorrent doesn't work most guns
when you talk about Australia they were
still in circulation okay
Australia with the mandatory buyback I
think they recovered what 1/6 1/6 of the
guns I think 600,000 something they left
over 3 million in circulation by the way
it also had not surprisingly once you
understand those numbers no effect on
mass shootings many studies have shown
that the gun buyback program didn't work
other countries did not pass legislation
they had the same trends and mass
shootings New Zealand did - I don't know
that you're saying well hon a second
wait a second New Zealand had a mass
shooting in Christchurch because that's
an older source well of course so did
Australia they had a mass shooting that
was committed with one of the remaining
three million guns who could have seen
that happen we've also tried to
implement gun buybacks in the United
States for going to a domestic level
here it resulted in surprise wait more
crime more crime when they did gun
buybacks here in the United States so
that's the practical here's something
that I think is important to understand
it's like you said you can't buy
somebody's rights yeah right this is a
pretty obvious a mandatory gun buyback
it violates the Second Amendment in a
major way sure Australia can pass it
because they don't have a second
Amendment they don't have the
Constitution that we have that's why I
think our country is better than theirs
and I also do wonder if they do manage
to use
just laid a branch to push this through
sure it would go straight to did
judicial and I would imagine they would
rule it unconstitutional is it still
gonna have say you're gonna run through
to at least two different questions of
first is it going to violate the Second
Amendment and the right to bear arms or
second is it going to be a taking under
the Fifth Amendment the due process
clause which is how governments are able
to say they can use eminent domain or
inverse condemnation to take property
from citizens in order to have it for
the public use now a main argument that
people are using right now even the the
Kathy Giffords website talks right now
about how oh it doesn't matter if it's a
taking we're just saying it's the police
power but they completely gloss over the
fact that you still have the Second
Amendment as an obstacle right well it's
important to note that the dissenting
opinions in Heller versus DC they
believed that it was not a private
citizen's right to own any firearms it
had nothing to do with magazine capacity
was just no no you don't have the right
to own a revolver or a shotgun at all
effectively unless the sheriff says that
you have the right to do it and this is
by the way why it's unconstitutional
you cannot buy back someone's right to
self-defense okay this this is important
with this they always sort of thinly
veiled this what the venire well we're
not gonna take people's guns away we're
just gonna buy them back well what if
they don't want to sell them back we're
gonna force them to well how are you
gonna force them to guys with guns Yeah
right this is one thing we really talk
if it's it's not voluntary by definition
if it's mandatory it almost seems as
though those would be oxymoron it's
terribly mandatory let's use an example
here if I mandate by law that you have
to sell me I don't know let's say your
grandmother your dead grandmother gave
you a bracelet and heirloom it's very
important right okay with you on your
deathbed and I mandate you know what you
have to sell that to me but I'm gonna
pay you for it do you care that I pay
you could it possibly be less relevant
why because it's priceless you can't
replace that you know what else is
priceless the right to defend yourself
and your family you have people giving a
rep Matt I think with Matt Schaefer in
Texas they're giving him crap because he
said no one can strip you their
god-given rights and then oh so it's an
ar-15 is a god-given right said this was
I think Alyssa Milano the serial
abortionist no listen ar-15 is not a
right but the ability to defend yourself
and your kin yes that is all right
that's not a right granted by government
but an inalienable right
granted by God and birth which means the
government can't take it away they can
only recognize it it just so happens
that firearms are the only way to defend
yourself against Marauders criminals yes
a tyrannical government it's a right to
have a self defense tool at your
disposal if and when the need could
arise and it's not by the way this is
important to note it's an inanimate
object right this is important that
people need to discuss this when talking
about guns it's not a right to use a
firearm unlawfully just like you don't
have a right to use a fork unlawfully
that's why we have laws regarding the
lawful use of firearms it's not a right
to kill which may be why the left is so
confused about it in the first place
they think that killing unborn babies is
a god-given right they're a culture and
a dogma of death so that's all they see
when they look at an armed populace I
see life
I see five hundred thousand to three
million defensive uses of firearms each
and every year in the United States
according to the CDC I see five hundred
thousand to three million crime stopped
rapes thwarted live saved lives of
mothers sisters daughters wives this is
a big difference and not just because of
conservatives and liberal and oh people
say oh I don't believe in labels made
I'm not talking about just left versus
right but let's say it's very stark
contrast between the founding fathers
and today's progressives see the
founding fathers to go back to what bill
said they drafted the Constitution and
outlined inalienable rights not granted
ever by government because they believed
in God they drafted the Constitution and
these rights because they believe in God
today's pro-abortion anti self-defense
left they would rather play God did you
enjoy that that was a video this is a
studio this is a microphone that's a
subscription box a notification bill
this is a mug that's the most important
description in all this because we don't
get to make a living here on youtubes
and save D monetize us for being
offensive
whatever that means it means pretty much
everything in 2019 so join up at a lot
of credit calm slash mug Club today you
get the entire Daily Show access to the
whole blaze catalog and this wonderful
hand etched mug and you don't have to
say goodbye